this video is sponsored by raycon
earbuds i have
never understood the negative reviews
about twilight princess
the game to me is nearly flawless and
extends upon the expectations
that fans had from the previous zelda
titans ocarina of time and a link to the
past did you like the dark world
boom here's the realm of twilight plus
unique wolf gameplay
did you like horseback riding boom
here's horseback riding plus
epic sword fighting did you like the
hook shot
boom double hook shot i mean claw shot
but everyone's entitled to their own
opinions of course so to each their own
but to me this expansive world has so
many
incredibly memorable moments landmarks
items
music and characters some of which again
point back to previous zelda games
pretty directly
like the skull kid from the lost woods
portion of the sacred grove for instance
in the first place the character itself
is a direct reference to ocarina of time
slash majora's mask which makes this
appearance the third
and final time that a skull kid shows up
in any zelda game
any canon zelda game i mean but besides
the fact that this is a very unique and
clearly
important reference to the fan favorite
skull kid exclusively from the ocarina
games
we actually do have some reason to
believe that this skull kid is the same
skull kid from the events of majora's
mask
in the first place for those who are
unfamiliar with the skull kid in general
allow me to summarize who he is very
briefly
skull kids are mischievously playful
childlike beings that inhabit the lost
woods and only make appearances in the
ocarina games and twilight princess
ocarina of time's sequel majora's mask
features one skull kid in particular
that was also present in the previous
game who somehow loots the majora's mask
off of the happy masked salesman
wears it and unintentionally becomes
possessed by majora and tries to crash
the moon into the surface of the earth
in a genocidal attempt to kill
everybody in it
but other than that he's a pretty nice
kid if you're interested in a pretty
spooky theory i did with the one and
only hyrulegamer about what makes a
skull kid for last year's halloween
special
oh what simple times those were i'll
link to it on the screen and in the
description below
anyway the skull kid from twilight
princess could possibly be the same one
from ocarina of time and majora's mask
because
most notably he knows serious song which
was a detail
important enough from ocarina of time
that he immediately became friends with
the young hero of time
simply for knowing the song also yes he
has some sort of horn-like instrument in
twilight princess as opposed to his old
flute in ocarina of time but if you look
closer
i think the horn he now uses could
actually just be a modification of the
flute
since you can see what looks like a
flute in the stick portion of the horn
instrument and he even used to use his
flute as a blow dart to attack adult
link
so you know he's probably used to a
multi-feature wind instrument at this
point secondly
the rather different looking face that
twilight princess's skull kid has
does not feature the beak mask that they
normally wear possibly because after
majora's mask happened
this guy may have signed off masks in
general which would be understandable of
course
his eyes are also designed somewhat
differently and the red to yellow
coloration and slightly
soulless look may actually be a
reference to the moon's eyes from
majora's mask
possibly signifying yet another
connection to that
skull kid thirdly this skull kit is
guarding slash
leading the hero to the master sword
that's kind of a
big deal that one would think would be a
task given to a rather significant
individual and this skull kid's
significance and lessons learned kind of
speaks for itself
finally i believe this is the same skull
kid because
of his lantern but why the lantern you
ask
well this is where the actual theory
begins but real quick let's head over to
hyrule field for a short message from
our sponsors of this video
raycon earbuds hi do you have ears
of course you do do you like using them
i'm sure you do
do you like listening to tunes with that
sweet sweet bass
obviously introducing the new raycon
everyday e25 earbuds which is their best
model yet with six
hours of play time seamless bluetooth
pairing and all-new re-engineered bass
quality
plus with their extremely comfortable
and noise isolating fit it makes it
perfect for working out
or just blasting some tunes real loud
without having to alert your neighbors
or your siblings because we're all
jam-packed indoors these days and what's
even better is these cute little earbuds
right here come in a variety of
different colors all of which look just
as sexy as the last and did i mention
that when you're done listening you can
pop them back in their cute little
charging case which holds up to
four complete charges before having to
plug it back in clearly if you have ears
this sounds pretty good and even though
these earbuds start at just half the
price of any other premium brand on the
market they sound
every bit as amazing so if you're
interested in grabbing a pair for
yourself
click the link in the description below
or go to www.buyrecon.com
mmb for a whopping 15 off your order
that's only good for a limited amount of
time
so why not go check today and without
further ado back to the video
the skull kid has never been shown with
nor has he ever had a reason for having
a lantern before so the fact that he's
shown with one here is a bit strange to
say the least
strange enough to mean something more
than just a simple character design
choice to theorists like you and me so
when i was thinking about this lantern
i decided to take a closer look at it
and soon discovered that it's not a
normal lantern at all
you see lynx lantern is a good example
of just a normal hylian made
oil burning lighting device but the
skull kid's lantern design is different
in a familiar way you see this one has a
spiky
almost menacing design that's rather
similar to another group of ethereal
beings that carry lanterns
pose or rather the spirits of the dead
in fact
skull kid's lantern is nearly exactly
the same
overall design and shape as the imposed
lanterns
and even burns with a supernatural flame
starkly contrasting with link's rather
ordinary looking one that burns with a
very not
supernatural flame so what in the world
is the skull kid doing with a po lantern
i asked myself
my first instinct was to theorize that
maybe this means that skull kid is
actually dead
since he's referred to as an imp and
there are imp pose in the game
and he can warp around the place and
summon these terrifying death puppets
and of course the ethereal po lantern
but in ocarina of time we're shown that
skull kids can warp around the place
anyway and these puppets may
actually just be puppets i mean who
knows maybe there are other skull kids
in the trees helping him out
and not to sound too elementary my dear
viewers
but he doesn't fly around the place and
he doesn't glow and you don't need
wolf senses to see him so my conclusion
quickly became
due to these factors and some evidences
from majora's mask that the skull kid is
immortal and therefore not
dead leaving us with one burning
question
whose lantern is that well it's on the
thumbnail it's the lantern of the hero
of time
now for some better background on what
i'm about to say next i
strongly recommend checking out my who
killed the hero of time video after this
one
as in that video i delve into the
reasons surrounding my conclusion that
i'm about to talk about in this video
again links are on the screen and in the
description below
but anyway it's my strong belief that
the hero of time was killed and laid to
rest
either unexpectedly or by burial
somewhere within the sacred grove not
hyrule castle but due to the regrets he
carried with him beyond the grave
he wanders the earth and twilight
princess as the wolf of light
the hero's shade and what do we call
restless spirits in zelda games that's
right we call them pose
and what do pose carry with them
lanterns but do you see a lantern on the
hero shade
no you don't i believe that's because
the skull kid has it but why would the
skull kid have the hero's lantern
well quite frankly because they were
friends close friends
friends to the end the hero of time
trusted the skull kid with his lantern
with the sole purpose of guiding the
next hero to the very grove where the
master sword was in slumber
awaiting the next sword master the
significance is all around us
the light of the legendary hero guiding
the hero of twilight to the blade of
evil's bane
led by the hero of time's dear friend
the shameful skull kid
finally redeeming himself after the
events surrounding the majora's mask
poetic redemption and that is my
theory about the hero's lantern and the
skull kid of the sacred grove did you
like it
be sure to give me a thumbs up and a
comment below so others can experience
it as well did you think i was off
somewhere let's discuss it in the
comments
and please be sure to subscribe to the
channel for much more juicy gaming
content to come
thank you so much for watching guys and
as always huge thanks to my supporters
of which i have several new faces to
show off
say hello to nick b kayla m chris b
jaden destroyer and time linked welcome
to my elite crew you guys and for those
of you watching if you're interested in
making my next video come true
and supporting the channel and receiving
some pretty cool benefits
click that join button below or follow
the links in the description to find out
how
also down there are links to my social
media pages so come find me on twitter
instagram facebook you name it i'm there
so come on over and say hey that's all
i've got for this one so i hope you have
a great rest of your day
also don't forget to check out those
other videos for more theorizing on the
skull kid and co
this is mass nintendo bandit signing out
[Music]
you